avant une annonce de ces menaces sont à
constater un regain d'intérêt pour les
destinations américaines pendant des
mois les tours opérators avait cassé
leurs prix pour attirer les touristes
opération réussie à new york où les
sites des attentats du 11-septembre
attire les curieux
le printemps est dans new york a
retrouvé sa magie correspondance pascal
golomer et tristan le braz ans un jour
la famille défunt ne visitera pas tout
new york
mais le détour par g 0 s'imposait deux
semaines avant la fin officielle les
travaux de déblaiement
c'est un immense chantier qu'ils
découlent devenu l'un des sites les plus
visités de la ville
cela représente une toute petite surface
et toutes les tours autour sont restés
on voit des dégâts mais ne sais pas
c'est pas aussi impressionnant on aurait
pu vite direction so car c'est à la vie
new yorkaise qu'ils veulent goûter à
cette atmosphère si particulière qui
avait séduit près de 350 me français en
2000 la fréquentation a chuté d'un tiers
juste après le 11 septembre
et puis les affaires ont repris peu à
peu aujourd'hui les spectacles sur
broadway affiche complet dans les hôtels
on retrouve le sourire
avec des taux d'occupation équivalent ou
presque à ceux de mai 2001 plus de 75%
fini les prix cassés qu'il s'agisse des
avions ou des boutiques new york est à
nouveau une destination chère du rêve ou
échangeables c'est vrai que le fait de
dire si jolie tiens on regarde le prix
leur dis oui l'assureur maladie mondiale
à new york
chaque touriste dépense en moyenne 1000
$ par ses joues john lui ne demandera
pas un penny comme tous les guides de
son association il veut seulement faire
partager sa passion pour new york
jusqu'aux stations de métro passion plus
forte encore depuis le 11 septembre
la ville est à nouveau plein de vitalité
évidemment ces parvenus à 100% mais je
suis très fier de participer à cette
renaissance un peu comme un ambassadeur
new york plus fier plus accueillante que
jamais c'est le message que la ville
veut envoyer aux touristes du monde
entier pour qu'il revienne au plus vite
et dépensent sans compter